police departments all over america are
being defunded even as violent crime
hits record levels and of course it's
hitting record levels precisely because
they're being
defunded so what do you do in response
to this we just made a documentary on
this question part of tucker crosston
originals
we looked at how people survived during
periods of chaos and anarchy when the
government refused to protect them
once new orleans nebraska los angeles
and talked to people
who have seen it in la we talked to
koreans who defended their property
during the 1992 race riots in which they
were targeted
here's a clip from that
the police heard a gunshot they
everybody got back to their car
just left the place david joe was in
koreatown when the riots broke out
it was april 29 1992
i would stay in my store as an extra
store manager
la's korean community has been
especially hard hit by the rioting
because many inner city stores are
korean owned we are
pretty much on our own so what should we
do so um you know
no option we we have to defend our store
and that's exactly what
jew and dozens of other korean store
owners did
the only one thing in my mind was a
mission
to protect our korean people as well as
koreatown
those guys were really tough and really
brave
really an inspiration to all of us so
the documentary is called surviving
disorder it's on
foxnation.com right now and we think
it's a good one
that's it for us tonight we will be back
tomorrow hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else